a friend of Oscar Pistorius tells the
court he had a big love for weapons as
he testifies at his trial for murder and
pistorius's defense counsel throws doubt
on the pathologist's autopsy findings on
reeva Steenkamp good evening from
fattoria we're a close friend of Oscar
Pistorius has been giving evidence in
the second week of his trial darren
fresco said Pistorius was mad to have
fired a gun out of the Sun roof of a car
they were travelling in Pistorius he
said laughed after firing the shot
fresco has been called by the state
prosecutor who as part of his case is
trying to build a portrait of Pistorius
as a man obsessed with weapons and a
disrespect of the law Pistorius faces a
number of firearms charges as well as
being accused of the premeditated murder
of his girlfriend Paul Harrison reports
following a day of graphic evidence
about the injuries he'd inflicted on
girlfriend reeva Steenkamp a more
composed Oscar Pistorius arrived to hear
friend Darren fresco described two
separate occasions he'd witnessed the
Olympian letting off a firearm the first
was with friends at tasha's restaurant
in Johannesburg fresco had passed his
gun under the table as Pistorius had
expressed an interest in buying a
similar one we had been to the shooting
range before and I knew he had a big
love for weapons and having been around
them for a long time my assumption was
he had competency competency with it
whilst leaning forward I said to him
there is one up your head positions at
that time in relation to you and the
accused how would you describe that
fairly close at that specific time
milady what then happened here then
taken the weapon under the table now
having warned that there was one up I've
seen a shoulder gesture which I had
assumed was cycling the existing bullet
out of the chamber after him having
taken the weapon and having cycled one
art what I don't think he had realized
the time that he had cycled another whip
another bullet into the chamber of the
gun and at that specific moment he had
pulled the trigger to at the time
supposedly make it safe none of us had
known where the shot had gone off what
was the accused reaction
instantly had passed the weapon back to
me under the table and he said please
there's too much media hyper army at the
moment please can you take the rap for
it but for pistorius's legal team there
were crucial emissions in frescoes
original statement no mention of
pistorius's request that his friend take
the blame no mention either of a story
that had been fabricated to protect the
athlete if mr. Pistorius had asked you
to take the blame for the shot going off
it was easy to put that in your
statement correct that you I did not why
did you not I do not know why do not you
make up a story that the firearm fell
out of your pocket why did you not put
it in that section 204 statement I do
not know milady fresco who'd earlier
been told he'd be immune from
prosecution over gun violations if he
told the truth was then asked why he'd
also made no mention of his instruction
to Pistorius the gun was one up or had a
bullet in the chamber and that it was
acknowledged with an OK by Pistorius if
my memory serves me correctly that's
what I remember that I had moved forward
he had moved forward and we were in
close proximity of each other yep that
close proximity
I asked you if you remember also does
not appear in your statement that is say
okay yes you did you see that is
evidence of great significance in main
evidence in your statement up with you
and even in the earlier
cross-examination there was no reference
to it it's the first time that this
comes out can you explain that I can't
then an admission likely to play into
the hands of pistorius's legal team keen
to discredit state witnesses fresco
confirmed he'd been following the
evidence concerning him on social and
mainstream media previous with this is
referred tracksuit events I saw that and
I never ever wear tracksuit pants unless
I'm going to jump what do you mean you
saw that mr. Frisco it's been on Twitter
so you've been following that part of
data the bits and pieces that I see on
the news doesn't matter where you look
where you turn where you go what you
listen to what you watch that's all over
the media m'lady if I'm watching the
news that's all over the news if I'm
listen to the radio is all over the
radio I understand it as a friend I'm
not blaming you for that I just need to
know that you followed the proceedings
not entirely no
and send out entirely but at least with
it was relevant due to your evidence you
must is my understanding correct yes it
is milady turning to events leading to
the second incident firing a gun out of
a Sun roof of a car a charge Pistorius
denies the prosecution was keen to paint
a clearer picture of the olympians
relationship with firearms fresco
Pistorius and the athletes ex girlfriend
Samantha Taylor had been stopped for
speeding one of the officers inspected
Pistorius his gun lying on the passenger
seat the accused that applied you can
just touch another man's gun so in the
policeman get the the firearm and
ejected the one bullet what happened
what it gives do he started telling the
officer now your your fingerprints are
all over my gun so if something happens
you are then going to be liable for
anything that had happened his firearm
license had been given to the the the
metro police officer to which he asked
him a question mr. pretorius then he
said well actually if you could read it
with state mr. Pistorius we are then
gone towards the ethyl square we were
going we landed up at the gourmet garage
for dinner milady something else
happened on route without prior warning
he shot out the sunroof instinctively
I'd literally just moved over to the
right hands out of the vehicles seeing
that the the noise had gone off above my
left ear
did you say anything apologies for my
language milady but I also feels mad
What did he say he just laughed milady
by that stage it literally felt as if my
ear was bleeding Barry ruse
cross-examination then brought to light
the three had in fact been pulled over
by police more than once that day what
was the first occasion for from not
having a number plate affixed to the
vehicle and what happened then we had
got a fine for this what happened to
define the fine had been paid who paid
it from the dealership had paid it mr.
dealership sense an otter pistorius's
legal team then revealed in km/h the
speed Darren fresco was driving at when
the car was stopped a second time what
was the maximum speed of doing anything
I can't remember that 260 on the
speedometer because that's something
that you should remember
I can remember fast i was driving that
day mr. frisco I've never traveled 260
but what I want to say to you of course
if I do that's something that I will
remember that's why our ski don't you
remember something like that no I don't
in her evidence last week pistorius's ex
girlfriend samantha taylor also in the
car that day suggested fresco and
Pistorius together discussed shooting a
robot or traffic light venting
frustrations over being stopped by
police not so argued fresco the
discrepancy helping Barry Roux blur the
reliability of testimonies from two
people who supposedly witnessed the same
incident before the firing of the shot
there was no warning that it was about
to happen no there was no talking about
it none milady there was no irritation
about it no because this is quite a long
time after we had been stopped there was
no one being furious about anything if
you know there was no one laughing about
it no out of the blue out of the blue
you know one nun m'lady I'm just trying
to think what we should do and now I
should treat the evidence of Miss Tyler
where she said that Oscar and Darren
were pretty anxious and a little bit
irritated with the policeman and so they
laughed and they said that they wanted
to shoot the robot and then Oscar shot
the bullet out of the sunroof
that would not be true according to not
not what I remember I'm trying to
understand how these that you have two
people in the car that can this mess so
dramatically about when and where and
the why the shot was allegedly fired can
your sisters my testimony is a treat
milady that's what I remember mr.
Pistorius will deny that he fired that
shot that is incorrect
welcome back to pretoria where earlier
this morning professor Gert Simon was
recalled to continue his evidence on the
autopsy on reeva Steenkamp yesterday
professor Simon told the court that he
estimated rever had eaten her last meal
about two hours before her death she was
shot dead by Pistorius at just after
three fifteen in the morning Pistorius
maintains that they'd gone to bed much
earlier at around ten and had shot her
thinking she was an intruder earlier we
took a trip to a gun range near Pretoria
to have a look at a Glock pistol we were
shown a weapon similar to the glock 27
gun that darren fresco said he passed to
Oscar Pistorius under a table at Tasha's
restaurant in Johannesburg the gun that
went off accidentally the weapon we
examined shares the same firing
mechanism as the glock 27 we were
interested to find out how easy it would
be to fire the gun by accident if it is
loaded one up and I drop it accidentally
this farm according to block cannot go
cannot miss fine other words dropping it
but let's say for instance I've got an
example it slips let me take my it hooks
on your on some other mysterious way and
now I'm going to pull it now you've got
to remember I've got to make sure that I
catch that little lever and it can fire
yes but handing the fire I'm taking it
taking an underneath the table yes there
is a possibility that it can hook on
something we don't know but by dropping
it now and the only way that the Glock
will fires by depressing that little
lever and a trigger defense counsel
Barry Roux arrived this morning primed
to question the professor about his
findings without the TV cameras looking
on his evidence is judged to be too
graphic
professor Simon had to vouch for his own
expertise telling the court he'd carried
out between ten to fifteen thousand
autopsies over a 30-year career again
the focus was on the somewhat grisly
subject of the contents of reeva
Steenkamp stomach the professor
testified that although it was not an
exact science he judged she had eaten
only two hours before death much later
than the defense case maintains he said
there were traces of vegetables in her
stomach under cross-examination
professor Simon admitted he didn't
consider himself an expert in this
particular field and that different
people digested food at different speeds
joining us to discuss today's evidence
is professor dirk von papen door our own
pathology expert who is head of the
physiology department at the university
of pretoria annex Crawford our special
correspondent who's been in court
throughout the trial and John Welsh from
the South Africa gun owners association
can I start with you professor you've
heard that the pathologist described
studying the contents of a stomach and
particularly the emptying the speed at
which a stomach empties is not an exact
science I would say it is scientific in
the sense that the ways that they do it
is is by barium follow through and
taking her x-rays on at different times
the other way is by swallowing a pellet
of nuclear technetium it's a radioactive
material and then with a guy gift Ella
they can determine what the time of
summer came clean and the follow flew in
the gardens I think one of the points he
emphasized is that we're all different
our stomachs are different various
factors will play a role in stomach
emptying if you are talking about food
specifically then caller ID rates it's
easily and i would say it depends on the
literature what what you're reading what
they say about 75% of the stomach should
be empty by nineteen ninety minutes and
about one hundred percent at 12 18
minutes in two hours but i would say
they are we also in the literature two
to three hours that is the average time
a little bit longer if it's porkchop's
fatty meal how does on the emotional
state of somebody affect this process
because that's a killer HR to this
astrology that is important the body
consists of the autonomic nervous system
which is two parts sympathetic and
parasympathetic now if you are
emotionally if you're in a fight
situation or argument then the
sympathetic nervous system will be
stimulated and therefore inhabit
stomach empty while till we make it
slower it will make it slower so if
everyone is relaxed have a glass of wine
some nice food in the normal stomach
pathologist was under cross-examination
today and particularly around that
specific area he was a very precise
witness but do you feel that Barry Roux
for the defense scored many points often
I don't think so actually I thought
professor Simon was a absolutely
formidable witness he was very very
thorough he stood to attention the
entire time he gave his his evidence
which was over two days everyone else
has sat down and he was very thorough
very measured very matter-of-fact you
gained even when he was describing the
injuries that he was extremely thorough
you know mentioning absolutely
everything that was on reeva Steenkamp
body and that went over into the
contents of her stomach he gave a very
long explanation about why he wasn't an
expert but then he backed it up by
saying that this was his theory his
conclusion or his assessment was based
on you know a decade at three decades of
a career that that involved this and he
was well used to investigating this and
he took great it the only time you saw
him slightly losing showing a bit of
irritation towards very rude was when
very rude was questioning his expertise
and Barry Roux was referring to one
article and the professor sort of
reminded him that not only had he at
least half a dozen articles in front of
him he had also spent 30 years studying
this and reading up about it and
practicing it we've got used to bury
rulers bit of a Rottweiler I mean he's
really been the star in a sense of this
whole trial today he was pretty meek and
mild he was very respectful towards the
pathologist definitely i thought he he
showed a very
a much more respect towards him the name
has done towards
all the other witnesses most of whom are
just ordinary civilians what picture
today emerged with Oscar Pistorius and
guns well we had a more evidence from a
friend I think probably safe to say a
former friend now because he's testified
very definitely against Oscar Pistorius
he's challenged his recollection of
events on two occasions he talked about
him firing a gun out of a sunroof the
car that he was driving this man is
darren fresco and another one another
gun incident when the gun went off at
tasha's restaurant in Johannesburg and
mr. fresco painted was trying to paint a
picture of a man who was obsessed with
guns who had a love of weapons who was
perhaps reckless and who obviously
didn't want to take responsibility for
his actions now on this occasion i think
very roo did score quite a few points he
really tore apart Darren Fresco's
testimony questioning why he'd left out
very very key parts of evidence such as
mr. Pistorius leged Lee asking him to
take the blame why you haven't mentioned
that when he first went to his lawyers
he certainly suggested quite heavily but
mr. kressler was more trying to save his
own skin than tell the truth and he went
on to to suggest that perhaps mr. fresca
had based a lot of his evidence on
hearing coverage of this trial through
television radio and Twitter and I think
that was very damning for mr. fresco as
a witness John let me turn to you you're
the gun expert here we've heard as Alex
said Pistorius described today as
somebody with a big love of guns he
owned his own gun we understand that he
was at the time of the shooting applying
for licenses for a number of other
weapons how difficult is he of middle
class mail South Africans well if we
talk about gun ownership in the first
instance if we look at about 50 million
inhabitants of this country and we look
at about 1.6 million firearms owners
owing approximately 2.2 million firearms
that is what typical day is in this
regard so amongst about 1.6 million
firearms owners owing firearms that is
nothing strange 20 those type of
firearms one must remember that in terms
of the South African law is first of all
a very strict procedure in order to get
licensed secondly one is limited with
regards to the number of firearms that
one mayor for instance the ordinary man
ordinary woman may not own more than one
handgun or shotgun for self-defense and
not more than three others Black Talon
bullets that cause maximum damage why
would anybody want those kind of bullets
those are typical self-defense bullets
over many years the Americans from where
we take the lead as well and because I
or the greatest manufacturers as well
they f through their research they've
established that an ordinary military
around knows bullet does not cause much
damage yes it can cause killing but one
must remember that in a self-defense
situation where there is violence
involved you want to stop the attacker
as quickly as possible and that you do
with a bullet of that nature that's it
for today remember you can watch
continuing coverage of the Pistorius
trial on Sky News at seven thirty in the
morning and a special program at nine
thirty
you